the topic of stretching before
exercising has become one of growing
scrutiny one side says stretching as
mandatory while others think you're
crazy to even consider doing it back in
my high school days stretching before
you exercised was a paramount activity
you were practically required to do it
and if you didn't you were cast out like
a leper but enough of my awesome high
school stories
let's see who's actually right well the
truth is this is an incredibly complex
topic and both sides do have some
beneficial points but one side is
actually more right than the other
ideally stretching would technically
support and improve the contractility of
muscles making them more flexible and
increasing their strength
really the effects of stretching comes
down to the mechanics of how muscles
contract which by the way is understood
very well firstly all your muscles are
made up of large bundles of muscle
fibers these fibers are also bundles of
strands called myofibrils inside the
myofibrils are the smallest unit of
muscle tissue called sarcomeres
which is where the actual contraction
happens in the sarcomere there are two
proteins that cause contraction myosin
and actin here's how a muscle
contraction works an ATP molecule first
binds to myosin once bound the ATP is
converted into ADP which gives the
myosin protein energy to move the myosin
protein acts like a pair of hands and
grabs the actin protein pulling it
inward the ADP molecule unbinds in a new
ATP binds to the myosin causing it to
release the actin and the cycle repeats
every time you contract a muscle this
process is happening okay so how does
stretching apply to this muscle
contraction cycle well in 2013 a
research team at McGill University
wanted the test of stretching a
sarcomere before contraction had any
effect on the force that it generated
for the experiment the researchers used
sarcomeres extracted from the abdominal
muscles of a rather the sarcomeres were
placed in a solution that put them in a
relaxed non-contracting state then an
activator solution was added which made
the sarcomeres contract upon the first
contraction with no stretch beforehand
the sarcomere generated the force of 24
nanonewtons the sarcomeres were then
stretched with micro needles and placed
in the relaxed solution and then
reactivated again this time when the
sarcomere contracted it generated a
force of 37 nanonewtons a 21% increase
from the previous contraction
the experiment proved that actively
stretching prior to contraction causes
the sarcomere to produce a stronger long
lasting contraction this phenomenon is
known as residual force enhancement
there isn't the concrete understanding
of how it works but several theories
have been put forward one Theory
believes that stretching slows down the
rate of detachment of the myosin from
the actin recall in the contraction
cycle that when adp unbinds from the
myosin protein a new ATP binds to it
making it attached from the actin
protein however after stretching for
unknown reasons the ADP stays bound to
the myosin for a longer period of time
increasing the time the myosin binds to
the actin this longer attachment to the
actin is believed to be the cause that
generates more force the action may be
similar to pulling a boat closer to a
dock if you're in a boat and pulling a
rope attached to a dock say for four
seconds instead of two you'll generate
more pull force on the bow thereby
causing it to move of greater distance
we now know that stretching increases
the strength of muscle contraction but
what type of stretching actually does
this well in case you didn't know
there's actually two ways to stretch
statically and dynamically static
stretching is stretching in a fixed
position you extend a muscle with no
movement for say 20 or 30 seconds and
you're done
dynamic stretching is much different
because you're actually moving the
muscle past its range of motion several
times dynamic stretching could also be
called warming up static stretching is
becoming increasingly unpopular because
more and more scientific studies are
showing that it does not improve
performance and doesn't really make
sense biomechanically this is because
sports don't require you to stay in a
fixed extension for 30 seconds on the
other hand dynamic stretching is
becoming more popular because it makes
sense biomechanically as it mimics the
mechanical movement in sports raises
temperature of the tissue and increases
blood flow to the muscle if you're going
to stretch before sport it's best to use
dynamic stretching however static
stretching isn't completely useless it
does have one important purpose
flexibility consistently extending a
muscle does make it more flexible
thereby improving the athletes range of
motion don't believe me try to do a
split stretch right now yeah didn't
think so
static stretching makes the muscles more
flexible by training the nervous system
to accept greater and greater extensions
by constantly stretch
muscle fibers this doesn't mean it
prevents all injury just actions that
require high flexibility like ballet or
gymnastics we can agree that static
stretching is useful for flexibility and
dynamic is better for strength but do
either of these stretches prevent injury
evidence for injury prevention can be
hazy conflicting and outright confusing
numerous studies have shown that
stretching does not prevent injury
however these studies focus solely on
static stretching and not dynamic in the
study published in the British Journal
of Sports Medicine researchers followed
over 2300 participants for 12 weeks they
had the participants perform 30-second
static stretches before and after
physical activity researchers found that
static stretching before and after did
not produce any significant reduction in
injury however they did conclude that
stretching can reduce some minor
soreness as the stretch group reported
24% soreness and the non-stressed group
reported 32% so interesting but not
significant however a study in Sports
Medicine did theorize an important
correlation between stretching and the
sport being played sports that require
high intensity cycles of stretch
shortening actions like soccer and
football require a resilient well
maintained muscle tendon unit that can
store and release elastic energy at high
rates if players are relying on static
stretching which most Dell do they're
more likely to become injured on the
other hand sports with low intensity
elasticity demands like cycling and
swimming are prone to less injuries and
historically require less stretching
both of these scenarios can give the
appearance that stretching doesn't
prevent injury players who rely mostly
on static techniques and play high
elasticity demanding sports are more
prone to injury because they're using
the wrong stretch on the outside one
would say sea stretching doesn't prevent
injuries in low intensity sports where
there is less required stretching
there's also fewer injuries which would
also support the theory that stretching
is not related to injury prevention more
studies are showing dynamic stretching
does improve performance and strength
and some flexibility however injury
prevention is still difficult to prove
in conclusion stretching is beneficial
if you're going to play a sport or
workout use dynamic stretching because
it increases contraction force raises
muscle temperature and increases blood
flow to tissue if
doing gymnastics or dancing you'll need
flexibility so do static and dynamic
stretching finally it's hard to know for
sure if stretching prevents injury but
you're probably better off to stretch
regardless and click the bell to
subscribe you know
[Music]